man I had some hope towards the end
there that was too many too many pawns
and as soon as I dropped my one pond
that was trying to help out in
constraining those three that was tough
I was tough and another thing that I am
another conclusion I drew play I came up
with playing against this computer is
that in so many instances having a
knight advantage night versus the
computers two pawns Wow does it still
make you work like really really work
okay I don't know if this is correct but
I think I've had some decent success
against it going with this line and
getting my knight to this square you see
about that move I can't push this pawn
just yet
got to get out for this diagonal I think
this next Bishop takes pawn is a threat
I know it's not I could take the rook
and then take this rook with the check
so that's not quite working okay now I
might need to do this I think it's
better it looks sad to do a move like
that but there's gonna be pressure on
this I try this line again and then push
get my each pawn rolling get my HP
unrolling this night is gonna be a
disaster
okay pawn push here the rook has then
direct sight of here and this bishop can
seeing so much better I think it's
important to stop this advance though I
try it this rook increases in mobility
and so too does this bishop but
hopefully this night is out of play
last time I did this the pond captured
and then well I don't know okay
this night is free to move I don't
really need him around for anything do I
he's watching over these squares but I
don't want to move this night maybe I
could move this night it takes I take
and then I have something here maybe if
I push here the Knights gonna jump there
maybe get this advanced centers there's
something more direct so if I do this
maybe the bishop occupies this square
trying to maybe shut the door on this
guy hmm
let's do this first and now run with
this Knight movin or movin or this
Knight manure what am I saying that's
when you know you have to quit that's
when you know you have to quit the
stream when you're saying manure instead
of a new maneuver oh man all right let's
go grab that pond let's grab that pond I
feel like I should have something like
if the computer is playing the black
side why would it give me a beating okay
I can't move my queen she has to watch
over this pawn push oh if the knight
goes here then there's Knight f3 checks
I think pushing here is good I feel like
I should really have something ooh
this bishop is not defending these light
squares can I get there can I get to the
light squares this has to be good for me
I don't want to allow this night to
exchange itself off because then these
rooks spring to life and then here over
here I feel like I'm so close to winning
there's gonna be some tactical shot
that's that's like kind of a nothing
move does that even do might start
sacking pieces sniffing a mane let's
keep it closed
that's the no soup for you move I think
I'm seeing it I think I'm seeing the way
to victory lane it doesn't have a
defense it's gonna weasel out it's gonna
weasel away I feel it a minute 30 I
should have this case the king wants to
make a run in this direction
just want to get my queen out doing
something I get my queen out doing
something
looking for mate on this square well it
might start stacking pieces soon start
stacking pieces oh it's gonna start
stacking pieces Queen here yes it's
sacking pieces over here 55 seconds oh
can I start my trash-talking yes where
you going now you're not so tough now
there's no defence what's the matter
whoa watch out for tricky forks I got
everything covered no fear Knight check
right that's all you could do it right
that's all you got the kitchen sink
variation Queen check Queen check
kitchen synched here it is ah man how do
I finish white off here mmm
I gotta savor the moment do you blame me
this thing gives me beating after
beating beat me six games in a row it's
making one to look at it's a chess
problem we were doing him earlier mmm
let's see King eh a bum game oh the
champ I'm the champ I want to get one
six that might be a good note to stop on
right there I don't know if I want to
play this beast again